hello Jessica Jones you are cheater you
were given every advantage allowed to
make mistake after mistake you can't
control yourself
you have known discipline just brute
force what do you want I want you to die
Gregory Salinger you smarter than both
of us combined the looks with that I
know you are it's not exactly a secret
so you know I can break your face I
barely survived him Salinger did this
let's go get him
I don't need your help and you don't
need mine he was unjustly arrested on
you cozia two maniacs people around you
get hurt
[Music]
everybody's got a story a beginning a
middle and end I'm late for work as what
super cat burglar you know what Jess you
do it your way I'm gonna do it my way
there's still a way this ends with me
respecting you is not my highest
priority right now
Jessica Jones you believe you could save
the world but you're terrified you've
already failed and you have because you
are armed and you never will
[Music]
he's still a hero if nobody thinks you
are like I give a [ __ ] what other people
think
you